c'est jeudi chroniques cinéma bonsoir
tania on commence par une autre
adaptation le pilot pen ou une autre une
autre
oui cette fois ci on veut revenir à la
genèse de piqûres par jour soit quand on
dit que oui en huitièmes conflit
l'éternel adolescent cette fois ci on
est donc dans son enfance voici donc un
extrait au moment où peter panne arrive
dans le monde imaginaire le petit il
porte le pont le pain et le guerrier le
plus brave des notre tribu
tiens tiens tiens la princesse je
présume
je vous remercie pour le compliment
ainsi je venais pas mais la star donc de
cette relecture de propane est ce que
c'est un film à voir je ne m'éterniserai
pas parce que non ce n'est pas un film
qui n'est pas du tout bien reçu on a
voulu faire du nouveau avec du vieux
malheureusement ça ne passe pas la barre
c'est mon avis c'est aussi l'avis des
critiques principaux dans les revues
américaines alors malheureusement
n'allez pas voir on passe au passé on
pense qu'un autre le monde de jack
c'est un coup de coeur absolument
sa femme extraordinaire que j'ai vu donc
cette semaine parce qu'il est présenté
dans le cadre du festival du nouveau
cinéma c'est l'histoire d'une mère et de
son fils séquestrés voici un extrait
rappelle-toi il s'était pas toujours au
pays des merveilles elle est tombée dans
un grand trou très profond oui mais
j'étais pas toujours ici
je suis comme alice là l'occasion se
présente
people c'est donc un film bouleversant
dans lequel on est dans le monde de jack
ce petit garçon qui a des longs cheveux
parce qu a pas décision évidemment dans
cette petite de ce petit cabanon un film
vraiment et géniaux c'est un film il
demande aux canadiens réalisé donc par
l'énigme ce qu'on connaît pas et qui
nous fait découvrir donc aussi le talent
de celle qui joue la mère bruit la
racine qui est excellente et de ce jeune
garçon au jecker tremblay qu'un non
francophones mais qui est originaire de
colombie-britannique et qu'on voit
souvent revoir
on est donc dans cette petite pièce et
vous voyons on les voit sortir
éventuellement mais les moments où on
est dans la pièce avec eux c'est ans
j'en ai des frissons s'envoie rue c'est
horrible c'est une histoire horrible et
c'est tellement bien raconter et leur
sortie toute l'attention après c'est
très très touchant alors film dur mais
avec une lueur d'espoir au bout de ça ce
n'est pas espérée d'une histoire vraie
c'est une fiction d'après une adaptation
d'un livre des fictions blum le monde de
jack donc et puis et puis et puis
intéressant l'histoire de mal à la qui a
été transposée au cinéma
oui c'est donc un documentaire qui n'est
minimale à la pour revenir sur
l'histoire de cette jeune fille qui a
été atteinte par une balle à la tête
alors que leur revenu à la maison après
l'école et donc lé thème cible des
talibans au c'est toute cette histoire
donc on la retrouve quelques années plus
tard la voici quelques clichés
alors au delà de la militante de la
révolutionnaire on veut aussi son petit
frère qui devrait elle est un petit peu
un autre viol explique en fait le
documentaire est ce beaucoup sur sa
relation avec son père et comment grâce
à lui et l'a pu militer pour le droit
des jeunes filles d'aller à l'école au
pakistan alors un film donc il prend
l'affiché cette semaine et en terminant
les choux documentaire non c'est pas
partout ça prend la fiche donc chez nous
dans quelques salles oui absolument
parce que s'il ya des différences jardin
diffuse est absolument et en terminant
on a beaucoup parlé de monica bellucci
la semaine dernière à lui on lui a parlé
exactement et bien le film ville-marie
prend l'affiché aussi cette fin de
semaine à compter de demain
très bien merci tonnes soit